a man died bro
a man died um
so i'm at breakfast right
i'm at breakfast one morning and
and uh
and the place i'm staying at man i
treated myself i the place i'm staying
was pretty nice dude they had like a
concierge breakfast so you go down there
you know and it's [ __ ]
you know i don't know who the concierge
was but i'll tell you this his wife can
cook i'll say that because they had it
bro they had it um but oh at breakfast a
guy died bro
a guy
oh
i can't even believe that that laugh
just came out of me and that was
that's satan bro
um but a guy died at breakfast a guy met
his maker and i don't know what he was
having
i didn't get a look at his plate
but uh
my friend had joined me we're sitting
over there and we are um
you know she was doing a crossword or
doing whatever brought her some joy and
there's a rambunction in the corner
and i didn't know what it was i thought
maybe it was one of those uh
charles and uh
you know charles and charlie's or
whatever where they shake the guy's neck
and they put the liquor in his face and
they shake your stepdad's neck or
whatever until he can't even breathe or
something
and then they call it you know they're
like uh hey here you go fatty you know
they say stuff like that to them but
they put the liquor in his mouth and
they got the whistle and [ __ ]
and then they you know put take a
picture or whatever they put sell you
like a magnet or whatever i thought it
was that kind of thing because there's
like a big rambunction
but then i look over and they're yelling
somebody's yelling 9-1-1 and i'm like
that is
that's old-fashioned that doesn't make
any sense really but
um
but then other people realize oh call
9-1-1 so because some guy's just yelling
9-1-1 9-1-1 and i'm like oh man
i don't know i guess that's i mean it's
definitely how it works but it's a just
an older way of doing it so anyway
people started calling 9-1-1 and then e
of they're just asking anybody to be a
doctor here
and dude when you're sitting there as a
man you're like damn you realize you
have
no skills bro that's what i realized
anyway i'm like damn they somebody there
they had the man on the ground and i
mean this brave guy came over
and uh
and he's suddenly the bravest dude in
the room because he knew skills
to do cpr
so he's doing it there's a nurse lady
there she's doing it and they're just
helping and then the rest of us are just
sitting there and i just felt like oh
man
i don't
have any
life saving skills
um
and there's something about that it hits
you you're like damn all the things i've
learned
and i haven't learned this skill i
haven't learned a real
and the worst part i'll hear is the
worst part
so they're over there they say they got
they're bringing him back and he goes
back to the other side i mean he's just
playing red rover with the devil over
there you know or with the lord i don't
know his backstory but that guy is just
they're like you know send you know andy
or whatever you know red rover you know
sin and and they're just he's going back
he's in and out and in and out and
they're like we're losing and we're
gaining and we're losing them we're
gaining them
and um and i didn't know what to do dude
and then this is the saddest part i just
started eating again
and i'm like oh my god am i the kind of
guy that just eats when somebody's
dying oh man and so that kind of broke
my heart i'm like and i remember just
like i cut into this sausage patty
and i'm like there's no way you're gonna
eat right now right
because it was like it was obvious there
was like a group of people that had go
on over to help and if you can't help
you got to stay out the way you can't be
over there just you know lighting
candles or like
you know somebody was there with his
wife so everything you know all the
corners were kind of covered and i said
a few prayers
but then
i just started eating this sausage patty
dude
and it [ __ ] honestly man it broke my
heart i'm like do i
i don't know it just there was something
about it it was just a lot man i'm like
oh
and i had one bite i'm like there's no
way i have another bite because you can
hear them doing the cpr and then i had
another
bite and i'm like oh my god bro
just stop eating
just stop eating if there's any time
where god is looking down at the earth
to see what's happening
it's when somebody's transporting
through
you know the portal between life and
death is open here
and this guy
is about to freaking andy doofrain his
way up there
and i'm sitting there
eating bro oh
it was so bad man
oh it just felt weird so
so that was that bro
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one